In breaking news
we've received reports of an explosion
somewhere north of the city we're still
waiting for the police to confirm
if there are any victims this story is
evolving rapidly
please bear with us this really loud
boom there was smoke
and emergency services have confirmed
that they've discovered a body buried in
the wreckage
we're still waiting for further details
collapsed details news an explosion
rocked gotham city earlier
we're now able to confirm that
billionaire philanthropist bruce wayne is...
if you're watching this i'm dead
this is a cold black
this message was automatically triggered
when i destroyed the cave and everything
it contained
we both know it won't take long for
gotham's criminals to realize the batman
is gone
and you can't count on the gcpd haven't
trusted us since
jim died gotham will need its protectors
more than ever
i'm leaving you the belfry as base of
operations
some of the technology is outdated but
it has the gear you need and all of my
files
you've always had my back when i needed
you i know you'll keep gotham safe
good luck and goodbye
no one talks about them
not a whisper word is said
for if you try to crush them
the talon strikes you dead
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new batman trailer for
gotham knights there's a whole bunch of
easter eggs in here i'll explain what's
going on with the story
and how it connects to everything else
so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos
i will do a giveaway for copies of the
game when they release it but it's not
coming out till 2021
so if you have no idea what's going on
with this it's meant to be a completely
new batman game franchise from the
makers of a couple of the arkham games
so it's not meant to be connected to the
arkham series maybe there'll be some
easter eggs for some of the arkham games
but these characters even though they
look similar to some of the character
models from the arkham series
won't be based on those the name of the
game gotham knights is taken from the
batman gotham knights comic book which
is about the adventures of batman's
extended family so as the trailer
implies
nightwing batgirl robin red hood all go
out because they think that batman has
died
we should say that the trailer claims
that batman and commissioner gordon have
died and that's led to this period of
lawlessness in gotham so they have to
step up
and it provides this ample opportunity
for the court of owls to seize total
control of gotham
but i think it should be said i don't
think any of us believe that batman is
actually dead
like he says he blew up the bat cave and
they're talking about it on the news
there was an explosion north of the city
i just saw this giant ball of fire and
smoke
but do you actually believe the batman
is really dead or is this all just a
ploy to draw out the real villain of the
game
behind the court of owls but the whole
idea is is the main characters of the
game at least for the most part are the
gotham knights themselves the other
extended batman family members that you
get to play as
nightwing red hood tim drake robin and
batgirl
the court of owls as you see during the
trailer are the main villains but there
are other major batman villains like mr
freeze that they fight during the
trailer so i'm assuming that most of his
classic villains will show up throughout
the game at various points
it is open world like arkham but none of
the areas in the game with the different
stories or missions
are level gated so you can go pretty
much anywhere you want at any point in
the game
i do like all the batman comic book and
movie easter eggs though for the batman
family members as they go around through
the different scenes
like code black alerts sent out for
times when something really bad happens
to
batman and they think that he's dead or
situations like nightfall when bane
broke his back and he couldn't function
as batman for a long period of time
so we pre-recorded a message programmed
to release to the bat family alerting
them that sh*t has gone down
this first person in the trailer that
gets the message is obviously red hood
then
batgirl his message confirms what that
big explosion was he blew up the bat
cave but there are
other bases of operation that he has
many different places and hidden storage
areas for weapons
gear that he needs around the city he
probably just blew up the batcave to
prevent any of the villains from gaining
access or stealing any of his technology
but also batman kind of makes it sound
like gordon died a while ago before the
events of the series way before he died
and the gotham city police department
has just gone to ruin since then just
gone total dirty
this is nightwing in blue of course he
says he's leaving the belfry to them as
their new base of operations
that's the secret base built inside the
old wayne tower in central gotham is
this really big vantage point which
makes sense for the game
it's just this heavily fortified central
location that's where batgirl is when
you see her get the message with all
these banks of monitors which is also an
oracle easter egg even though she's
suiting up as
batgirl during the game this is
obviously tim drake
in the comics tim drake is actually one
of the people who helped build the
belfry but in the trailer batman implies
that it's older
they haven't been using it in a while
and the tech is all outdated
then they do the obligatory suit-up
montage and roll out as a team to take
down what seems like a lot of low-level
groups of thugs around the city one of
them even seems like they're wearing owl
masks for the court of owls
there's a big montage that gives you a
look at some of their special abilities
that you can use during the game
some of it seems like gameplay mixed
with cut scenes then you get the big
court of owls reveal
all these creepy looking special coffins
are just cryo chambers built to hold the
talons when they haven't been deployed
on a mission for the court
so early prediction batman just found
out about a secret plot that the court
of alice had they surfaced later in the
game as much bigger villains and he's
trying to draw
them out by making them believe that
he's dead and letting the city
fall to a little bit of ruin to the
villains so that it's actually
believable that he did die
but in most of the stories where the
court of owls is featured it involves a
lot of batman
intrigue and politicking a lot of stuff
behind the scenes very game of thrones
so just expect a couple big story twists
involving batman's true fate there's no
official release date for the game other
than sometime during 2021
but there were actually some quarterback
easter eggs in the batman trailer with
robert pattinson but they're not going
to be
huge characters in the first new batman
movie it just implied that we'll see
some easter eggs for them and maybe
they'll eventually show up in the new
live-action sequels
at some point they're one of the biggest
villains that they haven't done in any
of the big batman movies yet and matt
reeves is trying to make a very
different looking batman trilogy from
the dark knight movies or even ben
affleck's batman
but you look at the riddler's card with
the clues that he leaves for batman
which is also inspired by the zodiac
killer halloween cards it has an owl on
it
you see some of the gauntlets that
batman wears on his suit
those look like the gauntlets that the
talons wear on their suits there's also
another scene where he's using the
grappling hook to fly up in the
staircase to escape these thugs one of
them is wearing an
owl mask but that aside i don't know
who's voicing batman during this trailer
it's not kevin conroy
it sounds a little like jason o'mara
who's done animated batman in a couple
of the movies before but it's hard to
tell
they don't list who the actor is on imdb
they just tell you who the gotham
knights are
but everyone let me know in the comments
what are you most hyped up about for
this new game
this is basically like the giant new
batman game that's coming out
obviously there's also the suicide squad
kills the justice league trailer i'll do
a video for that sometime soon too but
that's completely different studio
completely different storyline that's
not connected to this batman game
everyone click here to re-watch the
batman trailer a billion more times
and click here for the flash movie
teaser trailer and all the other big dc
movie trailers from dc fandom this past
weekend
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!